hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll long
time listeners will be aware of my
personal point of view on questions of
emergence and fundamentality there are
things that are supposed to be
fundamental to the universe ideas
Concepts that you cannot do without in
discussing the universe at the most
comprehensive level and then there are
emergent Concepts that are useful to us
at maybe a macroscopic level or some
other version of analysis the word
useful being very very important here
you just don't just make things up they
have to serve some purpose typically in
a scientific discussion the purposes are
you can make predictions they have
causal relationships to other things in
the world a table is an emergent concept
it's not in anywhere in the standard
model of particle physics or anything
like that but by saying there's a table
here that conveys a lot of information I
know things like I could put a cup of
coffee on it or sit down and read a book
in front of it and so on so when it gets
to human level questions like the self
that's something that it's a little bit
trickier to think about where it is a
more traditional way of thinking about
the self would have been that it's very
fundamental to what nature is how the
universe works is that there is an
essence of each human being and maybe it
changes with time or it evolves but it's
part of them there are plenty of
cultures which thinks it survives after
you die and so forth I of course do not
want to say that I don't think that the
self is fundamental I think it is very
much emergent but that's not the end of
this discussion when you say okay
something is emergent there's a lot of
questions that get raised by that out of
what does this concept emerge why is it
useful what are the boundaries how can
you improve the definition of it or your
understanding of it with the self that's
going to be an especially tricky thing
so we're going to think about that today
with Brian Lowry who's a social
psychologist at Stanford University he's
the author of a new book called selfless
the social creation of you and not to
give too much away of it but his idea
not coming from a physics background of
course coming from the psychology angle
here is what we think of as the self is
not immutable it is not fundamental it
is not absolutely there in some way that
can never be changed or our concepts of
it can never be updated not only he says
is the idea of the
self-constructed and emergent but it is
really dependent on other human beings
it does hearken very much back to a
recent discussion with Hugo Mercier who
says that the reason why we invent
reasons and and giving reasons for our
actions is because we want to offer them
up to other humans as reasons to believe
something so what Brian is saying is
that our notion of self necessarily
involves ideas of other people and how
they think about us if you say you are a
physics Professor you attach meaning to
that by assuming that your audience
knows what it means to be a physics
Professor what a professor is what
physics is and so forth and all the
expectations and all of the presumptions
that come along with that and this view
gives us the ability to imagine changing
the notion of the self if you want to
change your identity for example or if
you think that your identity is
misunderstood and you want to correct
those misunderstandings that is allowed
but communities matter you can't just do
it by yourself that's the interesting
implication of Ryan's way of thinking so
we're going to get into it occasional
reminders you can support mindscape on
patreon by going to patreon.com Sean M
Carroll those are the people who get
ad-free versions of the podcast and of
course get to ask questions for the ask
me anything episodes we always
appreciate every little bit of support
so with that let's go
[Music]
Brian Lowery welcome to mindscape
podcast thanks for having me Sean great
to be here you know I we will get into
the issues that you study for a living
that you talk about in your new book
selfless
um but I gotta start out talking like a
physicist just for a second because
we're talking about the self
the first question is should we think of
the self as part of the fundamental
architecture or reality or is this
something that human beings use as a
concept that they invent to make sense
of the world
oh I think of it as a concept being
invent to make sense of the world
um but who knows you know no that's the
right answer don't break don't back down
that you gave the right answer
what I mean is you know back in the day
we might have been cartesians and
thought that there was uh you know an
essence of our minds that was not our
bodies that somehow communicated with it
but we're these days were more emergent
disconstructivists right like somehow
this arises out of a whole bunch of
things
yeah I think it's um I think the self is
a social creation and I think that we
still under appreciate the extent to
which we exist because we're embedded in
The Social Network and that we have
there is the self as we understand it
ourselves as we understand them
right so we even if one didn't think
that even if one was not a Cartesian
dualist you might still have thought
that you could think of the self as just
things going on in your brain but your
point is that we need to take the rest
of the world into consideration as well
yeah but I don't think that even if
you're a hardcore materialist that's
just going on in the brain that without
the social interactions without
interactions among
different people you don't get selves is
what I'm saying yeah okay and the the
the craziest physics question I have is
I mean maybe this is isn't even a
question but there is a place where this
question of what the self is and how it
evolves comes up in hardcore physics
which is in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which is something that I study for a
living you know when you measure a
spinning particle many worlds says that
if it could be spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise there are literally two
worlds one of which a version of you
sees it's been one way and the other one
it sees it's been the other way and
there are people who don't like this on
the basis of saying yes but which one is
me
as if you know there's some essence of
them that has to flow through somehow
and I want to say neither one of them is
you we have to update our Notions of
personal identity in a world like that
but that's okay yeah I think that's
right I mean you know I used to be
really into uh theoretical physics too
as a lay person for this reason because
it's um it's this interesting
intersection between the physical world
our understanding of Consciousness
that's kind of what when you think about
the perception the Consciousness and the
more complex concept of self they kind
of all intersect in what you just
described right so there is the you know
there's the the I guess the ontology the
reality of the world because two you can
be spinning in both ways in one way in
one world and one way another world and
you could be observing it spin each way
in these different worlds but when you
say You observe it what are we talking
about that's when this conscious
observation kind of intersects with this
kind concept of self because now you
want to personalize that observation and
say it's me or not me now which me is
real like now you're going from
conscious
you know perception to something deeper
which is like personal identity yeah now
you're sending me two people right
that's one that's a a kind of a leap
that people don't understand like
conscious perception to people is not
those are not it's not I mean there's a
step between yeah that's what I want to
say people who want to say you know the
many world's point of view doesn't
comport with my notion of personal
identity I want to say your notion of
personal identity was never that good
thing that is I completely agree yeah
right good and good so that's thank you
for indulging me with that now we're
gonna move much on much more onto your
territory here um I like the you know
how you begin the book or in the book
early in the book
talking about the very basic idea of
where the self is like I talked recently
with
um Andy Clark who is a philosopher uh
and cognitive scientist who works on the
extended mind hypothesis right that you
know our our notebooks and our computers
and our wrist watches are part of our
our minds and I did ask him I said yeah
but like I think that I live right
behind my eyeballs
and you actually have something to say
about that yeah you know it's
interesting most healthy individuals
have that experience they're like in
there and they're right behind out with
you and just maybe three or four inches
behind their eyeballs looking out you
know controlling the Machinery of the
body yeah and obviously that's not true
right I mean any anybody listening to
this podcast like yeah that cannot be
true then you have to say like then what
is it and as science evolves I feel like
our answers to that have evolved but
they still end up being some version of
still an essential self in there it's
just is the essential self you know some
soul
is the essential self
um
you know brain architecture is it neural
Pathways but it's still that's just a
way I think for most people to still say
the same thing which is like I'm in
there as a soul
um and and it can extend beyond this
physical being too right it's something
more than this so you get that a little
bit with this kind of desire for
immortality of like uploading the you
know your neural Pathways and your
neural network to the cloud as if that
would be you right that's an interesting
assumption right are you saying that it
wouldn't be you or you're open to
thinking it would not be you would not
be you actually this is a diversion but
this is that's okay that's why we're
here I I am fascinated by this idea
because I also think it would not be you
I have a reason a set of reasons for
thinking that why would you say it would
not be you if you uploaded yourself into
the cloud well one I think that you only
make sense in the context like your
sense of self your identity only makes
sense in the context of other people so
you have to upload your whole social
environment right and for that to work
and you could argue do that too but you
know there's these interesting
philosophical games where you're like
what if you upload your brain but you
don't that you still exist also
physically are there to use is that
right and you'd say like that that
doesn't sound right there's something
there's something wrong right something
is you've got something wrong and the
question is what have you got wrong I
think what you got wrong is the
assumption that you exist as a pattern
of neural firings or something like that
I don't think that's how we exist
because you want to say that we exist
more socially or in a more embodied
sense I think I want to say we exist
more socially but I also I also think
this is a separate issue from I mean a
separate pointing point that I make but
I also think we exist in an embodied way
too but that's a I think a separate
compelling argument but it's not admired
I mean let's go back to the right behind
my eyeballs question is there a good
reason why I tend to think that I live
literally in my head if I'm going to
locate myself is that is that pan
cultural is that Universal does every
human being think that way or do
different kinds of people think that
there is a self that lives somewhere
else
you know it's a really good question so
I don't know in terms of the
phenomenology how how much that differs
I'm not sure what I what I know that
psychologists have studied what differs
is how people will how embedded people
think we are on the social network how
much they think that constitutes who
they are that varies by Society
um but this phenomenology of am I in
there I don't I'm not sure how much that
varies but you do mention that there are
out of body experiences for which we
don't need to violate the laws of
physics it's a it's our brains giving us
the impression that we're not inside our
bodies yeah what I love about that is it
also suggests the opposite that our
brains might be giving us the perception
that we're in there and that might not
be exactly right
so you know there's these studies where
I don't maybe you know these studies
where you can create you can reliably
create the out-of-body experience
um a simple way to do simple but the way
one way to do it is to put a VR headset
on someone have them look at themselves
from The Backs they see an image of
themselves and you know outside of their
body through VR and then you stroke the
person's physical back while you stroke
the Avatar that they're looking at back
at the same time and they will start to
have a sense that their self is in that
Avatar that's outside of their body that
they're looking at so this is a an
example we don't need drugs or uh
sensory deprivation tank you can just
induce the feeling that you're located
somewhere other than inside your brain
yeah and this is the one that people
know my guess is if your listeners know
are interested in this they might know
of the rubber hand oh yeah I know I know
that one but let's assume we don't yeah
yeah so that one is um so you put a hand
you put someone's hand account below a
table but you put a rubber in where
their hand would be okay and then you
stroke the rubber hand and you see them
they rub him they have a rubber hand
being stroked at the same time they see
they feel their real hand being struck
right and then after you've done that
for a little bit you go to smash the
rubber hand with the hammer and people
yank their hand back as if their hand
was going to get smashed because they
experience the rubber head as yeah it's
called the rubber hand elusion yeah
um and you can do that with the whole
body which is amazing so it suggests
that there's a way in which we come to
understand
our physical body or ourselves being in
the body or our body being ours
through these perceptual experiences
that it's not just how it is is
something that our minds have to learn
what strikes me is actually how easy it
is to give ourselves the impression that
we're outside our bodies or that our
bodies are something else like that I
think that that would be possible but
difficult and it's like yeah it just
takes five minutes with a flat with a
feather and a hammer yeah you know the
funny thing the one I love most is not
even these is the in basement effect
where you get people to incorporate
someone else's face into their own sense
of self how does that work that one is
where you um it's the same same kind of
effect except instead of
um I'm restrucking my hand and a rubber
hand or looking at an avatar I'm looking
at someone else so we're sitting across
take it from each other I'm looking at
your face your face gets stroked at the
same time that I feel my face gets
stroked and then later I show you photos
and the photos either a photo of you a
photo of me or a photo of a morphed at
differing levels and I ask and I ask you
just let me know when you see it when
the photo is mostly you versus not
mostly you and if you've had
simultaneous stroking when the photo was
let's say I don't know let's call it
50 you know two percent U and 48 uh me
you get especially but when it's 52 me
and 48 knew you still think it's mostly
you
only if I face with stroke
simultaneously so you start to
incorporate the other person's face into
your sense of self
I see so so there's there's two things
going on here one is just the photos and
there is sort of a natural I guess
implicitly what you said we're pretty
good at picking out what it's mostly us
if you don't Prime Us in some way but
then you you do this physical action and
and it starts blurring a little bit
correct and that just suggests that it's
possible to blur right like you would
think you would never confuse your face
with someone else's face and the
stroking thing about stroke you there's
a sense that there's some confusion
happening if I don't stroke you you just
been looking at this person then you
don't you don't see that effect
and all of this the ease of out-of-body
experiences and things like that is at
least nudging Us in the direction of
thinking that this the self is something
other than absolute and objectively out
there in the world yes I think so all
these things suggested there's a way in
which we are constructing the self right
it just it's it's not just it isn't just
there if something is happening right
there's some kind of process by which is
being created
and I think that you mentioned in the
case of the um morphing into other
people that there might even be a reason
why that is the case having to do with
closeness to other people empathy
something like that
yeah so their social psychologists who
talk about closeness as yourself and
other like you can think about like they
put aside the stroking and just think
about someone who's really close to you
in your day-to-day life you spend so
much time with them you get to know them
like it at some point closeness is about
incorporating that person's self into
your sense of self right and this sounds
and you know on the extreme it seems
um really hard to believe but you can
honestly start to confuse yourself with
someone else's self right you could
confuse for example something happened
to someone else you might think it
actually happened to you right if you're
close enough those sorts of confusions
can happen and in some sense because
your cells are being entangled in a
particular way they are coming they're
becoming merged that's one way to
understand it is this related to the
very basic psychological phenomenon of
people being over sharers or having
boundary issues
and maybe maybe all he wants to have
balancing issues maybe that's what makes
humans humans your baby
my cat's definitely have boundary issue
so I don't know I don't think it's
exclusively human
um okay so the lesson like you say the
the self maybe it's not only not as
objective as we think it's also there's
another aspect of that it's not as
immutable as we think the self changes
over time and
how should we think of ourselves at one
time versus another time is that
something that
the psychologists have figured out that
question I love the question because my
answer is so it's so ridiculous that's
why I love that question
I love that question because I think
that the self is fluid this is the most
extreme version and I haven't been I'm
not the first one to say say this by
long shot like Hume argued there is no
self there's just the illusion of
continuity itself right that you know
there's no stuff we put too much Doc in
in its continuity for sure the self is
constantly shifting you just don't
experience it that way
um and there are good reasons not to
experience it that way so it's it's
useful to have a sense of stability but
it could just be wrong it could just be
that's just not true it's only an
illusion
I don't know if you know Lori Paul who's
a philosopher we had on the podcast and
she studies transformative experiences
so the question is how do you make a
rational choice if choosing a certain
thing is going to turn you into a
different person who has different
values
whose whose values should
rule there I don't think there's a clear
answer there but it's clearly a
fascinating question it is and and you
get an easier one too you don't even
need the transformed experience you just
need time right people who do work
saying like how how nice are you to your
future self uh you don't know who that
self will be but you make decisions
right now they get to that it will
affect your future self right how do you
think about that what's your
responsibility to that that person that
you're not right now is there a right
answer to this question
there is please tell me okay well I did
I heard a talk once by Philip zimbardo
who famously did the Stanford Prison
Experiment and so forth
um but it was about how people have
different attitudes towards time some
people are past oriented
present-oriented future oriented and his
claim was that you could easily test
this psychologically to figure out which
one you were and it correlated much more
strongly than other psychology test
results with outcomes in life careers
you choose things like that and you know
it kind of did make sense to me like I
do care about my future self more about
my past self but I think there are
definitely people who are the other way
around
yeah you know I that's a good question I
I mean a good thought like how do you
think about
how much you value the past versus the
present version of your self yeah
um
yeah you know it's an interesting I
hadn't thought of it as an individual
difference but it is I think that does
make it really interesting individual
difference
so let's move on to the where the rubber
hits the road here for you this claim
that
um
the self is very social very created by
a community
um I mean let me I'll let you
lay out the basic idea here like I mean
I think that intuitively I might have
said the self is inside me and there's
other things which are interactions with
the rest of the world you want to you
want to update us a little bit there
I want to say that um
unless it's a strong social
constructionist argument basically so
for those of you don't know that it's
just the idea that the self is a social
construction by which I simply mean
that who you are is created by the
interactions you have the relationships
you have the people around you
um and so there's not it pushes against
the idea that most of us probably
um feel or ex way we experience
ourselves as
essential essentially they're like
assault I think that's how most of us
experience ourselves like again going
back to in there itself but more
important like there's a Core US yeah
that was somehow imparted to this
physical vessel I don't know at
conception at Birth or whenever you
think that happened
um and I am pushing against that I don't
think that exists at all it's not
genetics it's not that doesn't make the
self the self it's
the story you were born into story that
came before your birth the culture you
exist in the the networks and
relationships and people who construct
that culture the people who raise you
the friends you've met the relationships
you've had all those things are what end
up constituting your unique
individual self
is there's is that an extremist version
of something for which there's a more
wishy-washy version that says that there
is something that is purely me inside me
and also how that react interacts with
the community around me matters
I think that most people probably have
some version of there's a a me and
interacts with the environment and it's
changed the environment I think that's
that's the most most
people's kind of like uh
reasonable
understanding of how it works and I and
I push against that simply because I'm
like okay tell me that me part what is
it
uh because if you keep pushing hard on
it it just starts to I think it it
starts to crumble a little bit and I
think you end up falling back on
something like a soul which they don't
they would never start with they'd be
like no no this is scientific like what
is it that it's temperament or it's
genetics and you know these these kind
of things where I'm like is that really
what you mean by the self in genetics is
I think um
um in particular I think lazy because
genetics don't determine what we are I
mean it's maybe it's potentials made I
mean certainly has some effect it's not
like I'm denying the importance of
biology of genetics but it's not
determinative right it's not enough to
tell you who a person will be you can't
read someone's genes as you know a
patent conception of birth no who they
are like that clearly is not how it
works so but if you want to say the self
then really is socially constructed you
know how do I what what is the
definition of self that we're using here
like as opposed to for example identity
you know I might people might want to
want to say that their social identity
is socially constructed but there's
still something inside me that I'm
making up
yeah and I guess again this is where I I
like to ask questions as much as much as
make claims I'm like what tell me what
that self is like when you take away all
those social identities like what are we
talking about like so I just never know
what we're talking about are we talking
about even when people say temperament
I'm like you only really mean how that
temperament is understood or experienced
right like you don't you don't mean the
temperament per se you mean how it
manifests or how it makes you you
there's some there's some other there's
some interpretation necessary right
that's what I think anyway this is my
this is this is I'm not gonna make this
is a
um a claim about truth I'm gonna make
this a claim this is like my view of
what people actually mean so I could be
wrong yeah oh we could all be wrong
um but it does remind me I hate to keep
bringing up old podcasts but it does
remind me of uh Hugo Mercier who we
recently had on the podcast who wrote a
book with Daniel sperber about
um reason and reasons and reasoning and
their claim is that the idea of having a
reason for doing something rather than
just doing it uh is uniquely human and
uniquely because we want to offer
reasons to other people it is uniquely
social it's not if we lived completely
by ourselves that we would not attach
reasons to our actions
yeah that's that's interesting you know
what I love about these ideas they they
contact so many other ideas right so
this is like when it's it really is I
think we're coming to see
the importance of
um
our social nature and it may be in a
different way and I feel like there's
something in the air around this a
little bit
um and and maybe it's these like huge
these big
societal level issues like climate
change or the rise of inequality effect
on governments like democracy right and
you look at these big issues now that
affecting the world and they seem to
revolve around how we engage with each
other as human beings right to some
extent so
what do we owe each other
what what do we what role do we have in
in affecting other people's lives it's
like moving away from
a rugged individualism like you just
cannot account for or help us solve some
of the biggest issues we face today it
just doesn't work I think and so I think
we started to look and see and
understand the degree
um the depth of the interdependencies uh
among human beings so you want to say
that not only is this sort of more
accurate prescript uh description of the
self but normatively thinking of
ourselves this way is going to make us
better human beings
I would hope so I mean you know I don't
have a lot of Hope for human beings
sometimes
you know I think
this View
that we are constructing each other and
are constructed by others
it should change the kind of questions
we ask in the kind of society we we love
it okay is what I would say but there's
not this is I'm not Utopia I mean in the
sense that if we got that there'd be
we'd have tons of problems to address
and the society would have to shift in
in so many significant ways that it's
hard to even know what problems would
arise right but I do think that way of
thinking is more
accurate like I do think that that we
are the idea that we are individuals who
can make choices that don't affect
others is just on the face of it not
reasonable
well the other point you made which
which I thought was a great one is that
the moment we're born we have identities
we're embedded in a social Matrix and it
wasn't our fault right like you know who
we are in many ways is already there and
we can't really claim credit or be
blamed for it 100 I think um the way I
try to I what I say is like we're born
into a story that's already ongoing like
I think you have the sense of like I'm
here now the story starts right
it's like clearly there was a lot going
on before you showed up you just stepped
into something you didn't understand
right
um and it's and it's not that's not your
responsibility like you can't you know
you don't determine what's going on
before you get here but while you're
here it seems like an interesting
thing to imagine how you can participate
in the story
and
it it becomes operationalized when you
just imagine
being asked the question who are you and
what are the answers that we give to
that so
what what are the answers that people
actually give as a psychologist and what
are the ones that matter to you
yeah so you know this is where there's
cultural differences so there's a
there's studies that look at these
questions like I am and you get blanks
and and more individualistic societies
will say things that are like I am six
feet tall and I am you know I am a
basketball player whatever is these
things that seem very individualistic
and then in other societies people say
things like I'm a son I'm a mother you
know
uh I I'm a caregiver so things that seem
to have more of the social aspect those
are things that I care about
um and I think the social ones
um and I think those are the ones that
make us who we are
um I think saying for example even when
you say something like if I said like
I'm six foot tall I think the reason
you're saying that is not just to list
your absolute height is to say something
about your height relative to other
people even there even things that don't
seem social I think really are capturing
something about people's relationship to
other people when you think about
yourself I think you're thinking about
others I guess one way to make this real
is I've been told that if you're at a
party and you meet somebody
you're not supposed to ask them what do
you do for a living that's a boring
question there's other questions you
should ask but I don't know I I think
that's the most obvious one to ask what
are your professional opinion about this
you know I won't here's the thing about
it I think that it's nothing necessarily
wrong with the question but I do think
they're more they're more interesting
questions to ask
um mostly because I think people
separate their professional lives for
the rest of their lives in a way that
makes the question makes the answer that
people give less interesting right and
makes them less interesting to talk to
but wait a minute say more about that
because I think that when people think
about their work they again because they
separated from their lives and you ask
the question what do you do for a living
what they're going to do is like click
into this other person that is uh in
some sense
separated from who they believe
themselves to be right like they're
going to tell you about their work life
and if they're not excited about that
it's going to be a boring conversation
do you not say that you're a psychology
Professor when people ask you who you
are
uh I certainly don't most of those
people are weird when you tell them you
think that's true
physicist also works for that by the way
um yeah you know I like that you know I
like to ask people I like basketball
what are you excited about right now
okay that's the most exciting thing
going on right now for you okay
that that's that's the kind of question
I like to ask people and and that could
be work you know most people don't
respond with that but it could be work
well I think and again this is my
physicist training kicking in but I
think of this in terms of course
graining right like if you ask a person
who they are there's literally an
infinite number of two things they could
say and they boil it down to a few Pat
answers and and what you're aiming for
is to give answers that convey the most
information in in the fewest words right
and and maybe
thinking of ourselves as socially
constructed selves would alter our
choice for which aspects of ourselves
really matter
and I guess the question is like what
kind of information do you want right I
mean
if you want what I'm looking for usually
is an opportunity to
close the social distance
when I'm when I'm meeting someone new
right and by that I mean like I want the
opportunity to for them to have an
experience of being closer to me right
and I think that's just a more
interesting interaction
um and so it's not necessarily the most
information but I would say the from
their perspective
the most intimate information they're
willing to give me as someone that does
okay
that's a tricky one now I'm going to
start thinking about that
um I hope no one asks that it might ask
me anything episode what are the most
intimate facts about you is she willing
to get that you're willing to give it
I'm willing to give yeah they don't have
to be that into it I suppose but but so
he's over to ask about your background
for example right that was a that was an
entry point that's for you to tell me
something about your life or about your
music right that that is what I'm doing
is saying like how can I create a sense
of closeness quickly right how to log in
how to make it comfortable for you to
ask me something personal I see you're
revealing you're revealing your tricks
[Laughter]
for the audience listening over audio by
background he doesn't mean my personal
background he means the the video of the
of the office that I'm in right now that
we chatted about before we started
recording
so this is great I don't know you I know
you moved from California to Baltimore I
know that you're an aspiring bassist I
know that you're married it probably did
not have an office in your previous your
podcasting office in your previous place
did not just had one little tiny room
that I use for everything yeah I know
the the deprivation of it all it was
terrible
but yeah okay I mean it uh
I don't know I mean when I when I think
about myself when I give the answers at
the party when someone says tell me
about yourself
to what extent are the answers that I'm
going to give really ones that Society
has suggested to me over the years
versus things that I've come up with
myself
um I think you're gonna give the answer
that you feel is most culturally
appropriate in that moment right and so
that in that sense it's going to be the
not so much what Society tells you you
are but what Society tells you you
should say what matters yeah what's
society says matters right
I mean yeah because I'm talking to
another person I I have an idea of what
they would care about and
that's going to affect what I tell them
yeah
100 like you try and what you what human
beings are really good at is trying to
have smooth interactions with other
human beings are they good at that
really I've not noticed
like you're really good at this like you
have a podcast you're like you're very
personable guy it's like you try to you
want to make it work right you know like
to be tough to have a conversation if
you wanted to go smoothly that's what
people like that's true I just it's true
all right but okay let's let's uh raise
the stakes a little bit I mean I'm it's
a little bit hard for me because I
always want to like play The Devil's
Advocate but I'm totally on your side
about many of these things so it's
always fun to see how it affects how we
actually think about issues in the world
so
gender is that something that the
community just made up
it was a really interesting one is the
one this is the one I'd love to talk
about because it's so it's so
interesting and it also the one that's
most likely to get me in trouble exactly
and that's that's fine those are ratings
cold
so look I think that again biology like
humans reproduce sexually so there's
just there's just a re there is a
biological reality underlying sex gender
as I think about it is not that gender
is not the biological sex it's meaning
that we layer atop usually atop
biological sex
um and I think that is a social
construction which is different from
saying it's not important it's not
saying it's not real uh and it's not a
saying that it's
um
that there's no
there are no parameters that have to be
respected in the construction of gender
right but it is but I do think that it's
much more flexible than most people
experience as as being
um that it varies More Than People
imagine it does and that as societies
evolve the understandings of gender
evolve
and what does it mean to say that gender
is something that Society uses as a role
that you know what do I have a gender
when I'm just by myself or is it only
when I'm out there in the world
um
I think you have a gender when you buy
yourself to the extent that you have a
self when you're by yourself
um I think that the gender is
one of the most important ways that
Society organizes
um
so yes well I think that you have a I
don't I think you have a gender when you
buy yourself because you have a
conception of self when you're biased
when you're by yourself but that is a
function still of your your
relationships and interactions you have
um I think but I do think your community
constructs gender so there's a societal
construction but I'd like to be a little
bit more nuanced and say a community
construction
agenda well it's it's very
um compatible with again bringing up
previous podcast conversations with
Sally hasslinger the philosopher who
talks a lot about social construction
and we talked about gender and her point
is just like you said it doesn't mean
it's not real you know when you socially
get together and you build a bridge the
bridge is real but you could have built
a different Bridge right you decided to
build that bridge rather than a
different one and and our Notions of
gender and other things are similar to
that yeah and the example I like to use
the metaphoralities as more money okay I
don't think most people would not say
money is not real but money is only it
exists as an idea right you don't you
don't have there's not there's nothing
physical it doesn't require anything
physical
um it's really like it's it's in our
interaction and our expectations of each
other our beliefs in each other right
our beliefs and how others will be a
that's what makes money powerful it's
incredibly powerful but it it's a
construction gender I think is is like
that
I I love that example because it really
relies on sort of a shared set of
beliefs and expectations and agreements
right like there's and and we don't ever
signed a contract you know you're not
like asked when you're six years old
please agree that a dollar is a dollar
or something like that but like you say
you're you have no choice you're born
into the society there are certain rules
and you do play along for the most part
and it's I mean it's again yeah you come
into a story already being told and you
understand it's important so you learn
its importance and people teach you and
it's important right it's not just you
just and it's from nowhere it's like
people engage with you in a way that you
learn what it means to be a man or a
woman
I I guess one of the
things that people who are in the more
socially conservative side of things
worry about is the idea that people can
just decide what they are they can just
decide I'm gonna I'm gonna identify as a
dragon or or whatever and how
is that just okay or is that
so unrealistic that it happens very much
we don't need to worry about it or
what's the give and take between me
deciding what I am and Society deciding
what I am so this is where it's
something for everyone to be mad at me
about so
conservatives don't like this idea which
I think is fine like being if you're 6'2
with the beard and a lot of muscles you
could be a woman like that that's not
not problematic from my perspective how
the world operates the way the world
works
at the same time this is where liberals
will be upset with me no one you just
can't just decide that's just not from
my perspective that's just not you don't
have to worry about it because it's not
possible
I can't decide like right now I I
present as a man I think of myself as a
man most people I engage with understand
me and believe me to be a man so it's
fine if tomorrow I said I was a woman
that would not make me a woman right I
care just decide on my own to be a woman
right this is what it means to be
socially constructed and exist within
the community so my community has to
accept me as a woman for me to be a
woman I'm not a woman until my community
accepts me as such
I see so that that kind of makes sense
to me I guess
um one possible loophole there is uh
what if there was a trans person who
identified as a woman but nevertheless
still passed as male
is that it would be but I don't see in
their past this is what's important this
is we can talk about race two here they
pass yeah they're still a man from my
perspective okay
okay but there it but there is another
perspective that says inside they are
psychologically identifying as female
yeah ah okay so this this is this is
where this is the new odds this is where
it gets complicated and I'll give an
example about race and then come back to
gender yeah good so Rachel dolezales the
people remember she was this person who
was born as a white to a white family
it's a white girl
um identified as black from her what she
says like most of her of all of her
remembered like she thought herself as
black and so she started to present as
black as well
um I think was in Spokane really
committed to a black community uh issues
of the black community represented
herself as black understood herself as
black and then the community saw her and
accepted her as black but they didn't
know that she was born yeah into a white
famous white girl and then at some point
it was discovered that she was born a
white person and then the community
rejected her claims that she was black
okay so what I say about that is
she this is now ontologically she was
born white so she was white
she then became black she was black
and then this is the important part I'll
come back to gender now then she became
a white woman that wanted to be black so
she became a not black woman
so I wouldn't say she was a white woman
I'd say she's a not black woman
and this is important because for my the
way I think about it is it's both the
your view of yourself and the community
view of you when they
um when they align that that determines
what you are not what you would like to
be not what they think you are but for
my all intents and purposes again it is
a social construction what you are
and so when you talk about someone who's
like say a trans person who passes as a
man but thinks of themselves as a woman
I would say that they they exist in some
liminal State when they're in
communities that don't see them the way
they see themselves they're not really
they're not really either one of the
things you know on in terms of autology
at that moment so yeah I mean it makes
perfect sense if we're moving beyond the
naive essentialism about these
categories that there are going to be
liberal cases edge cases complicated
things and and that's fine and it's not
a flaw right yeah like there's you know
there's a place where it's like I don't
know it's Monopoly money money people
say no what it is in the context of
Monopoly I mean it's just like it's a
there's a way in which there's these
things that are
um
complex cases if what you require is the
uh agreement between the conception of
self and the internal not internal this
is another thing that gets complicated I
don't know how new much and what you
want but I want all the details
I see that as like um
not as a disagreement between yourself
and the community but a con some kind of
conflict between communities because
that conception himself has to come
somewhere okay
right and so there's a way in which
there's some sort of
disagreement between
communities is how I think about it
that's a very good point so we all live
in more than one community so I I keep
sometimes saying Society but you are
politely correcting me by saying
community and and it matters because
we can be different selves in the
context of different communities 100 and
this is easy to see right but then you
just have to push it once you see the
easy case you have to push it to harder
ones which is you're at home for your
parent like that's a very particular
identity but if you go out I don't know
you go out for a vacation and you leave
the kids with your your parents their
grandparents it's a different you right
or if you're out having drinks with your
friends that might be very different
than you than you at the office the
people can understand that that's easy
to see
um you just have to push it a little bit
harder to see the point I'm making right
but in the social media era sometimes we
cross boundaries as far as the
communities are concerned and that gets
us in trouble
100 I mean
we I think we've always crossed
boundaries but they haven't necessarily
come into contact as much as they do get
in social media
um you know people some people live in
very different lives and different
different communities right
and social media
has a way of in terms of broadcasting
all these lives to similar audiences
then you get you can get a little bit of
trouble
and I mean how
prescriptive or normative can we be here
I mean is it is are there right and
wrong ways to identify and and shape
ourselves given what the community is
trying to tell us like at some point can
we just say the community wants me to be
this I'm just not going to go along
you know this is that's a this gets into
another really
um hairy issue of like free will and I I
try to I lied that a little bit we can
talk about it but
I think let's stay with a gender Force I
get I think you can
move between communities and be
different selves in those different
communities right so you might exist in
a community that you feel like you don't
have control over they refuse to accept
your the conception of gender that you
prefer and so you you you move into
another Community we'll accept that and
and you feel more at ease and there are
many people who have that kind of
experience so
um I think we we all move between
communities and have different levels of
you know comfort in different
communities or
um comfort on different dimensions in
some communities than others
how does this drive with the idea of
authenticity I'm going to bring up yet
another recent podcast I don't know why
I'm talking so much about the self on
these podcasts maybe maybe it's an
important idea but um I just talked with
Scott Cleary who is uh as a historian in
some sense of philosophy and she wrote a
biography of Simone de bouvoir who
argues that we find meaning and
mattering in our lives by getting in
touch with our authentic selves and
everything you're telling me calls it to
question the idea that there is any such
thing or doesn't it
I don't know what authenticity means
like this is one of those things where I
I get it I mean people love the idea of
I'm I'm me I'm like my authentic self
right I don't there's a version I just I
truly just don't know what they mean I'm
not saying that there's no such thing
but the way people talk about it the
license of authenticity I think is is
probably
uh not coherent
I remember when I took an English class
as a sophomore undergraduate and I think
we were reading Eugene ionesco or
something like that and our professor
was talking about the masks that we wear
in different situations different social
situations and I was you know I was
young and naive at the time I figured
that he was going to go on to say so we
should remove those masks and be our
authentic selves but his actual lesson
was you just got to pick the right mask
for the right situation there's no
there's nothing under the mask it's just
a matter of which mask you're putting on
that day yeah I was gonna you know I
said this and I also I said this in a
recent podcast somewhere it's like it's
masks all the way yes all the way down
but but maybe I can well let me ask it
rather than state it is it a coherent
thought to say I can choose which mask
to wear
that has I choosing in there and I know
that's the Free Will question but what
you want to do a lot which is fine
I want to say yes but I think the right
answer isn't though
you know I think I should say this like
I I experienced like like most people I
think in that I have an experience of
living behind my eyes too I have an
experience of making all these choices
in life and
thinking that my outcomes are affected
by the choices I make and feeling
constrained by this situation and that
if only they'd let me be my true self
I'd be happier like I have all those
experiences I just don't
when I examine them
I just don't think that's right that's
certainly how it feels to me okay I just
don't think that's right but okay I mean
maybe I think it's fun something is
finally sinking in to my thick skull
here so I think I am getting something
it might be okay to talk about
desires that I have or wants or
aspirations without necessarily
connecting them to the idea that they
reflect a true self underneath I mean I
could absolutely say I am not happy in
this situation I would like to change my
situation
yeah I mean like you have experiences
you have feelings the the question is
just like what's the source right and
when you locate the sources like some
true essential self I'm like that's
probably wrong right that's that's what
I'm saying it's I'm not saying you don't
have these experiences or you don't have
these feelings or you don't have these
wants and needs I just think it's really
really hard it may be impossible to
truly Identify some singular source of
those things and certainly if there's a
singular source
I don't know as a as a materialist I
don't think it's the soul yeah yeah
is is the temptation to
Identify some singular Source or even
just talk about a coherent self
um more or less a western slash modern
invention or I mean I know that some
people talk about
um capitalist societies as being more
individualistic and other societies as
being more communal Etc I have no way of
judging whether that's true or just you
know a fun story to tell yeah so you
know I
talk a little bit about about this that
they're um
professors of Classics who argue that
our conception of self is a relatively
recent creation that and say
Classical Greece
um that there wasn't the sense that that
things uh emanated from your you know
Immortal Soul right like that you'd have
an experience you could say like the
gods breathe That Into You what what
something something moved you but it
wasn't necessarily located in a self and
then you look at literature those people
will point out that there wasn't really
a long after literacy and writing there
wasn't a tradition of rioting from like
a first person perspective into a very
very late like people point to Saint
Augustine's confessions as the first
major work that takes on a first-person
perspective of the world
um and all that to say that like no it's
not clear that our conception of self is
the only one that humans have had
focused on as as we look through history
um
so no I don't I don't know this is the
only way for us to think and some people
also suggest that
um
that this conception of self this
individual conception individualistic
conception itself is necessary possibly
for a capitalist Society I don't know
that you would say the capitalists
produced it but they certainly go hand
in hand and that if you believe in free
markets as we discuss them now you have
to kind of accept or really have deep
faith and individual choice and freedom
of choice well the idea of standard
um utilitarianism is that each person
has a utility and you add them up and
you know there's no sort of non-linear
effects that people can individually be
muddling along with Society is going
great or something like that yeah yeah
and this is right right and they and the
capitalism depends on that as well right
this is like the the best for me my own
personal greed will somehow end up
producing the best outcomes if everyone
else asking their own self-interest as
well and self-interest is understood
very narrowly so I did after while
reading your book I Googled when was the
first first person narrative and of
course people don't agree right there's
different claims they never do but uh at
least one of the interesting candidates
is the song of songs in the Old
Testament uh no with interest it was
very interesting to me I'm not a really
an Old Testament to scholar by any
stretch but I went and read it it's like
really racy poem these two people like
you can see why they don't talk about it
very much uh but it is also in the
voices of a man and a woman there's a
chorus in the background right and
they're expressing their desires in no
uncertain terms and it's a
it's always hard for me to imagine what
it was like to be a person living back
then like was that considered shocking
was that you know that that way of
talking unusual or was it just an oral
tradition that we just don't have any
access to these days I don't know
that's an interesting one I hadn't I
hadn't seen that one but that that makes
sense
um and also it's hard to know exactly
what like I haven't read it I actually
read it a long time ago I've read
recently so I have to go back and look
and think is this really first person
yeah those Details Matter like there are
people who say that Shakespeare invented
the concept of a character in literature
which yeah I don't know that that would
be a stretch but okay
um but again one of the ideas that I
thought was provocative that you put
forward is that the idea of a self
limits your personal freedom in some way
like it it circumscribes certain things
that you either can do certain
capacities certain privileges you have
in the world tell us about that a little
bit
I'm curious why I was provocative
because once I think I mean sometimes
that one seems to me to be almost
so obvious is to be uninteresting
so the idea is here I'll just say the
idea and then you can tell me why why
strike is provocative the idea is that
when we say what we are when we say who
we are when we give any definition
definition has to include what is inside
and what is outside
right like you have a definition has to
exclude as well even if it does that
implicitly and whatever we exclude when
we're talking about ourselves is by not
by definition a limit on what we are or
what we can't be
okay that makes perfect sense actually
when you put it that way but I guess the
the provocative aspect of it would have
been in my mind that you're sort of
attributing these limitations to
selfhood rather than other aspects of
our
um
existence in the world like I don't know
it depends on what we I guess if if the
self is entirely socially constructed
then maybe they all count but I mean
obviously how much money I have or uh my
status in society my job those limit
what I can do in the world yes but uh
are those is is the argument going
through those being aspects of what is
myself
no not necessarily I mean sure we could
but if you think of yourself as like
um a dad or if you think of yourself as
a man like take gender like buy
definition you're accepting limitations
right and you can send them in your life
like it's not it's not just an
abstraction right like if you think of
yourself a man as a man and you behaving
as a man because that's what part
requires to understand yourself in that
way that there are things you do with
things you don't do right now you might
have more or less stringent by some
people's you know
um conception ideas of what it means to
be a man but you once you say you're a
man you are accepting some kind of
limitation
I guess the flip side of that is that
one reason why people like traditional
roles so much is that it gives them a
set of Clues as to how to treat people
and yes it does and how to behave as
well right I mean I think I have the
chapter called hugs and straight jackets
and and this is kind of the point which
is we when we think of who we are it's
really important for us to maintain that
sense of clarity about who we are we
think about authenticity people care
about other things even though I said I
don't know what it means because it's
really like Integrity of self that's
right this is who I am it matters to me
and that suggests that those boundaries
those limitations are comforting they
they give you a place in the world they
tell you what the world looks like it's
um it's a perspective it's a place to
stand yeah it's a place by which you can
a location from which you can make a
judgment
um about who you are and what the world
is and your place and and there's
something deeply comforting about that
but in that is also limitation right
right I I like that a lot because even
though I don't agree with them it helps
me understand the anxiousness on the
part of people who really want certain
old roles just respected forever I mean
it makes your life easy you know the
decisions you have to make the way you
treat people things like this if there's
a if there's a script you can just run
and it never deviates then a lot of your
decision making is is made much easier
yes I mean it's it's it's it's
um if your decision making is made
um much easier and the world is made
more sensible
yeah
right like it's easier to have it's hard
to have meaning in the world where you
don't where you don't understand your
own place in it and when people start to
disrupt the nature of that meaning this
is this is why I think there's not a
Live and Let Live on issues of
significant identities right what people
care about other people being able to
change their identities because it says
something about their their their own
place in the world right I mean people
are really committed to having Clarity
in terms of how the world operates and
they place in it and these identities
play a significant role in that is that
something that we should strive in your
in your personal view to get better at
to have a little bit more relaxed point
of view with how other people can
through their own identities
I think yeah I mean my attitude toward
this is like look if someone asked to be
something I personally like you say if
you tell me right now like I think
myself as a woman I'd be like I'm I'm if
that's important to you I'm with you on
that like that that's my personal view I
think it's important that we understand
that we are in this together that's what
I think is important and that when you
ask to be a thing whatever it is if you
think you asked to be a podcaster right
like that it's a request that you also
understand that request has consequences
for me right it's not just what you want
to be like what you want to be does
affect me and I think there's a loss of
or insufficient
understanding on all sides I think
there's asymmetry I think we when we
when they're people who are really
committed to being a certain thing and
we deny them that and sometimes we
denying them their sense of humanity I
think that's a bigger burden a place on
someone but it's not the case that it's
no burden to ask someone else to accept
identities that aren't don't align with
the way they experience the world okay
yeah that's I think that's a perfectly
fair point I mean one I don't know this
is a trivial or profound example but
some people get upset when they see
other people walking outside in public
wearing a mask
they think that it is somehow insulting
to them which you know
and I I kind of get it right because
it's kind of what what they think is
that they're being judged right like
they're just walking down the street not
wearing a mask and this other person is
wearing a mask you might say well let
them do whatever they want but in their
minds this other person thinks less of
them because they're not being as
socially conscious or safe by by
adopting this practice yeah yeah I mean
everything that you do is being
interpreted by someone else right as in
a way that's meaningful from their
perspective right not from the world the
world is you experience it and so if if
you wear a mask and
um I see that as like questioning me
like or an easy example is like your
vegetarian go out to eat and you're like
oh I don't eat meat people will feel
that it's like questioning their their
choice to eat meat and yeah you know
some people will feel uncomfortable with
that yeah I mean we're all connected in
these ways right your choices and your
decisions are not somehow irrelevant to
mine but but maybe it's getting better
in some sense or or maybe like we're
still struggling to work through these
things another thing I think of which
might be a trivial example is that
certain conventions or meetings now will
have name tags that are color coded you
know the certain code means I'm happy
with physical contact give me a hug
another one says you know we can shake
hands but don't get too familiar and
another color says don't touch me
and
some people really get upset at that
they like they mock that they're like
you know why are you trying to be so
explicit about these cultural norms that
are supposed to remain unspoken and
Universal
yeah you know I think there might be
differences in the degree of clarity
that people want and the degree of um
Conformity so Clarity and now let's
separate those things like Clarity
because you can get Clarity by having
the badges but it suggests a lack of
Performing suggest like people are
making different decisions and
um I think that lack of Conformity can
be discomforting as well
so let's since we're winding up near the
end of the podcast here uh the other big
topic that you sort of just drop in
there in the book uh that I kind of love
is the fact that human beings are really
aware of our own mortality
yeah we're gonna die uh and and we have
a understanding of that in a way that at
least arguably other animals don't and
that affects who we are and who we want
to be and what what we want our legacies
to be because we we unlike other animals
have the concept of a legacy
so how does that feed in what what is
yeah what does that have to do with the
self
yeah so I think of itself as like if you
want to have a sense of meaning in life
itself is critical
um and I'll I'll give you quickly a
psychologist think about meaning is
needing three things one is coherence
right you have to understand the way the
world works and a symptom of your place
in the world it has to make sense the
world just needs to make sense coherence
another's purpose means like you get up
in the morning you have to have
something to do like this purpose the
third is significance sometimes it's
called matter like you need to you need
to believe that what you do matters
beyond the present moment right it can't
just be it bad is now and it's it
doesn't matter any any further than that
and I think the self is credible to the
first and the third so the self is a way
in which we create coherence of the
world it's a way that we understand
ourselves which is what obviously it's
embedded in the word uh it's almost
tautological like we understand a sense
of
ourselves in the world like Who We Are
where how we're related to other things
and other people
so the self is I think in large part
the way that we make sense of the world
it's coherence
um and then in significance and
mattering I think is the most
interesting because it suggests the self
is it's kind of like a time machine
so the self allows you to think about
how the past is connected to you right
like the past is not just the past like
you could think in terms of your
ancestors your history the story of your
parents how you came to be all these
things are connected to you and it also
allows you and this is the part that's
really important for video life it
allows you to project yourself into the
future
think about how the things you do right
now will reverberate even past your
death and it allows you to
connect to larger things for example
um you can feel connected to the nation
include that in yourself
and then when you physically pass the
nation persists or you believe well
there's a way in which you believe that
you will persist okay so it allows for
this symbolic immortality and so and
this is the kind of what the research
focuses on the researches Theory called
Terror management Theory it focuses on
this concept that human beings are aware
of their own mortality as such they they
seek ways to
um experience symbolic immortality and
one of the ways they do that is by
connecting their sense of self
to groups ideas that will live beyond
their physical being and you can do
things like in experiments where you
remind people of their death they will
um tell you that for example their
Nation will last thousands of years
longer than if you don't really like
them of their death right these sorts of
things where it looks like death
um convinced people to
um
Concepts communities that extend there
extend their lives symbolic looks like I
like the name Terror management Theory
it makes it seem it maybe it's even just
true that
whenever self-awareness sneaked into you
know the human mind and psychology uh
it's just so terrifying the the
existence of ourselves existence of
embarrassing past events the the
existence of our future demise that most
of our
most of what we have to do is just
manage that Terror somehow and live
productive lives nevertheless man that's
that that isn't that isn't that the
I don't know what it is we have to learn
how to play bass yeah something
something you know keep keep our
vibrations out there in the cosmos
exactly all right last question then
um I always ask this question of
psychologically oriented people on the
podcast so do you think that your
research your academic work in this area
has changed uh your own psychology or
how you behave or think about yourself
oh that's a really good question
um you know whenever I talk about this
book and all them shoes will happen now
the so the self selfless the book I I
feel
more
aware of how my engagement other people
affect them hmm
um and I'm much more sensitive to the
interactions I have with other people
um
and
I feel
like
it's also a better person
that might sound that might sound
strange
um and that
um
I try to engage more deeply
um I try to be more thoughtful about the
experience of the other person not just
with me but like where they where
they're from what their experiences are
outside of the interaction with me and
and I think it makes it makes when I do
that it makes my day-to-day experience
much better because it's surprising how
much it affects what they reflect back
to me and the way they engage with me so
it really changes my interactions and um
I feel like that's changed me right and
this is this is where the kind of
because I believe in the book right I
think I'll be differently
um people interact with me differently
and I'm a different person because of it
and I hope that they are better people
for the interactions as well no I love
that and maybe the flip side of what
we've been talking about most of the
podcast which we haven't said out loud
is that if ourselves are constructed by
our communities then we are part of
other people's communities and we're
constructing their selves and that is
something that we should keep be mindful
of as we interact with other people
yes I mean I think that we should
definitely be mindful of that as we
interact with other people I think
there's something to be gained when we
when we do that like we gain something
ourselves and we we provide something to
others and I think societal will be
better off if we really thought hard
about the degree of
of connection Among Us among all of us I
think that's good advice Brian Lowery
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast thanks for having me
Sean I really appreciate it
[Music]
thank you